[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien que vous avez passé
un bon weekend nous sommes le lundi 20
février voici le programme de ce soir
chaque année l'annuaire du monde
politique le trombinoscope déserne
plusieurs prix aux femmes et hommes
politiques français et cette année c'est
une nouvelle fois une yvelinoise qui
reçoit le Prix de député de l'année
après il y a LeBron Pivet Aurore Berger
a été désigné la semaine dernière par un
jury de journaliste politique c'est la
première femme présidente du premier
groupe politique de l'Assemblée
nationale le récit de cette soirée par
notre journaliste Julien Leroy le Salon
de l'Agriculture ouvre ses portes samedi
prochain rendez-vous incontournable pour
les producteurs et éleveurs du monde
entier les ruches les ruchers de
l'espoir situé à gatuis dans les
Yvelines seront présents pour faire
goûter leur miel récolter de manière à
respecter l'environnement et les
abeilles l'apiculteur Raphaël Berardino
n'intervient presque pas à laisser
ruches dans un état semi-sauvage nous
parlerons avec lui de sa technique de
production il est notre invité et enfin
comme chaque lundi nous terminerons avec
du sport quels sont les résultats
sportifs de ce week-end nous ferons le
point avec notre journaliste Mickaël el
midoro nous ferons aussi la découverte
d'un jeune pilote de karting qui a déjà
l'étoffe d'un grand mini Montin Arthur
Lorimier est arrivé troisième au
championnat de France junior de karting
et il est aujourd'hui pilote à
l'international il rêve déjà de faire de
la Formule 1 nous parlerons avec lui de
son ascension au haut niveau et
justement avec nous en plateau notre
journaliste sportif Michaël midoro
bonsoir alors de quoi est-ce que vous
allez nous parler ce soir alors on va
parler de la Coupe de Paris avec Mantes
le FC Mantois qui s'est qualifié pour la
finale au dépend d'un vrai cours on
parlera également de la coupe des
Yvelines on parlera également du match
Ginette Hoche un match entre deux lycées
le Sainte-Geneviève et le lycée Hoche
qui s'est terminé par la victoire de
Ginette dans une ambiance sulfureuse on
verra ça dans un instant et dans cette
partie
karité Arthur laurier bonsoir bonsoir et
vous êtes venu avec avec votre père
Lionel liami bonsoir alors Arthur vous
avez commencé à faire du karting en 2020
juste après le confinement qu'est-ce qui
vous a plu dans ce sport
je sais pas vraiment ce qui m'a plu mais
je sais que depuis que j'ai essayé je
pense que je suis fait pour ça parce que
le sport automobile
je sais pas comment l'expliquer c'est
une passion qui s'explique pas c'est ça
on en parlera plus en détail tout à
l'heure et avec nous également un
apiculteur des Yvelines Raphaël
bahardino bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
serez présent au salon de l'agriculture
le premier et le 2 mars c'est un
rendez-vous incontournable salon de
l'agriculture c'est c'est une vitrine
importante c'est la première fois que je
vais hyper participer et c'est un moyen
un peu de se faire connaître
à la fois dans les Yvelines et puis un
petit peu dans la région puisque je fais
essentiellement du local donc voilà
dans un instant plus en détail mais
juste avant je vous propose de regarder
la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera toujours un
peu brumeux sur l'ensemble du
département selon Météo France au niveau
des températures il fera environ 3 à 2
degrés dans l'après-midi nous devrions
avoir quelques éclaircies et à percevoir
le soleil comptez 10 degrés du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et 11
degrés vers Houdan et Rambouillet et
demain il n'y a pas de fête à souhaiter
puisque ce sera Mardi Gras alors Michael
est-ce que vous allez vous déguiser
demain non pas vraiment ce n'est pas au
programme enfin je suis pas sûr que la
direction afro mais bon pourquoi pas je
vais réfléchir ce soir et autour du
plateau est-ce que vous allez vous
déguiser demain pour mardi gras
forcément très bien allez maintenant on
va passer aux informations du jour dans
les Yvelines avec Gabriel Gonthier
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenues
pour deux rêves parties dans la nuit du
dimanche 19 au lundi 20 février la
première était organisée à Versailles la
présence d'une cinquantaine de personnes
a été constatée par les policiers
quelques heures plus tard c'est à HR
qu'une rêve partie a été signalée une
quinzaine de personnes étaient présentes
aucun accident n'a été signalé mais les
organisateurs ont été conduits au
commissariat des perturbations mais
cette fois du côté des lignes de train
sur Twitter la SNCF a annoncé des
difficultés sur la circulation des
lignes l Égypte pendant les vacances
scolaires du 20 février au 5 mars en
raison du manque de personnel le trafic
devrait reprendre normalement le 6 mars
samedi 18 février des militants de
Greenpeace et d'autres associations
étaient mobilisées pour une action
nationale au travers de 37 villes de
France dont Versailles au programme de
la soirée action d'extinction des écrans
lumineux et des enseignes le but réduire
les consommations d'énergie
inutiles à l'heure de la sobriété
énergétique nous nous sommes mobilisés
pour recouvrir les panneaux
publicitaires lumineux qui restent
allumés nous demandons à au gouvernement
d'interdire les panneaux numériques de
publicité ils sont très énergivores ils
consomment beaucoup autant qu'un foyer
en un an si l'ONG constate qu'à
Versailles l'extinction des insignes
lumineux et plutôt bien respectés ils
souhaiteraient que le gouvernement
interdise totalement les panneaux
lumineux et que les enseignes soient
éteintes quand les commerces ferment
avis aux fans de sport maintenant
d'après nos confrères de RMC certaines
épreuves des JO 2024 en extérieur et
disposant de place debout seraient
accessibles gratuitement dans les
Yvelines il devrait s'agir du BMX Racing
du VTT ou encore du golf à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis le
début des tirages au sort le 15 février
de nombreuses internautes se sont
indignés face au prix excessifs des
places pour assister aux épreuves et on
termine avec cette information insolite
le plus célèbre couple de souris était
de sortie samedi 18 février à l'espace
Saint-Quentin de le Bretonneux tout
l'après-midi les mascottes ont défilé
pour le plaisir des enfants et des
familles à l'occasion de cette journée
deux places étaient à gagner pour le
célèbre parc d'attraction un moment
féérique qui a rassemblé de nombreux
curieux dans le centre commercial
[Musique]
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news on en parlait en début d'émission
la députée yvelinoise Aurore Berger a
été sacrée député de l'année 2023
c'était lors de la 31ème cérémonie des
Prix du Trombinoscope parmi les critères
retenus par le jury son accession au
poste de présidente du groupe
Renaissance ainsi que sa ténacité et son
consensus Julien Leroy était présent à
l'assemblée nationale pour assister à sa
célébration Aurore berger honoré l'élu
yvelinoise et présidente du groupe
Renaissance a reçu le titre de député de
l'année 2022 lors de la cérémonie des
Prix du Trombinoscope à l'Assemblée
nationale ce jeudi 16 février le jury
composé de journalistes récompense les
personnalités politiques dont le
parcours a été remarqué ces 12 derniers
mois je suis très honoré je suis même un
peu émue pour tout vous dire qu'on a été
élu pour porter des convictions pour les
assumer et je crois que c'est ça qu'on
attend de nous et puis on attend aussi
qu'on exerce ce mandat avec beaucoup de
la dignité parfois elle s'échappe un peu
elle s'évapore un peu de l'hémicycle et
c'est à nous d'essayer de lui remettre
selon les membres du jury pugnacité et
consensus caractérise Aurore Bergé
première femme présidente du premier
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale en
parallèle de sa maternité ont été des
critères de sélection au titre les
politiques succèdent à la chef de
l'hémicycle brune Pivet elle aussi
Illinoise je crois que les électeurs
peut-être s'ils sont pas trompés on est
lisant des femmes qui ont je crois du
caractère qui sont plus que nazes qui
sont déterminés comme les gens esquima
remis le prix la dit résiliente en ce
qui me concerne je crois qu'en effet
c'est peut-être un qualificatif que je
peux employer c'est une manière de
rendre hommage quand même au dévouement
des politiques c'est une manière de
sanctionner aussi les résultats parce
que c'est une compétition là la
politique et puis pour moi c'est une
manière aussi de montrer qu'il y a
quelque chose qui nous dépasse tous
politique et journaliste qui est la
République qui est la démocratie de
nombreuses personnalités ont été
distinguées pendant cette trentaine
cérémonie des Prix du Trombinoscope
Fabien Roussel secrétaire national du
Parti communiste français a été élu
politique 2022 et Gabriel Attal chargé
des comptes publics séviomètre le titre
de ministre de l'année
le salon de l'agriculture est déjà
bientôt là et l'ouvre ce samedi sur le
site Paris Expo Porte de Versailles et
le département des Yvelines il sera bien
représenté second territoire agricole
d'Île-de-France les producteurs sont au
rendez-vous toute cette semaine nous
recevrons dans le 7 8 un artisan ou un
éleveur du territoire ce soir focus sur
les ruchers de l'espoir avec Raphaël
Berardino alors vous avez fait le choix
d'une apiculture extensive qui préserve
la santé de l'abeille plutôt qu'une
apiculture intensive alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus comment
est-ce que vous procédez concrètement
déjà en apiculture intensive vous avez
souvent vous déplacer les ruches vous
avez besoin de les déplacer toujours de
les mettre au maximum en fait de ce
qu'elles sont capables de produire
souvent il faut les nourrir il faut les
déplacer enfin il y a beaucoup
d'activités autour de autour de ça pour
qu'elle produise au maximum
et l'extensif on va les laisser vivre en
fait elle va produire moins il en faut
évidemment plus si on veut on veut
arriver à en vivre mais par contre on
intervient le moins possible de façon à
ce qu'elle peut vivre toute seule en
fait alors on n'est plus dans une
situation où on pouvait laisser les
abeilles vivre sans rien faire voilà ça
c'est plus possible c'était vrai
peut-être il y a 50 ans mais c'est plus
vraiment
pour plein de raisons mais voilà les
pesticides les maladies
levarois enfin tout un tas de facteurs
qui font qu'on si on abandonne les
ruches
c'est d'ailleurs un peu la problématique
qu'on peut avoir aussi un peu dans les
Yvelines c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont des abeilles mais qui s'en
occupent pas ou pas suffisamment ça veut
pas dire qu'on s'en occupe pas
l'extensif ça veut dire que on les
laisse faire quand on peut et puis quand
on doit intervenir on intervient mais
ainsi une espèce c'est l'abeille noire
alors l'abeille noire c'est notre
abeille endémique donc local
je suis à côté et j'ai une partie de mes
ruches qui sont dans le conservatoire de
la baignoire à Bugnon donc le canif ça
ça en fait l'objectif en fait
effectivement de protéger cet abeille
qui en fait se trouve être
en danger assez fortement lié à toutes
les importations en fait de différentes
de différentes variétés qui viennent un
peu de partout et qui sont pas forcément
adaptés à notre à notre environnement à
notre à notre climat etc et donc
l'hybridation va faire que on perd en
fait des caractéristiques génétiques de
notre abeille et qui vont venir se
mélanger avec d'autres avec d'autres
abeilles et qui au final vont dégradent
en fait
la résistance en fait de ces abeilles
extensive
autour de autour de Galluis un petit peu
plus côté Rambouillet
et j'en ai 300
répartis par des ruchers maximum de vins
de vins
alors c'est pas tellement une question
de goût en fait alors je moi je récolte
par rucher et chaque en fait chaque
chaque pot a le nom de son du rucher qui
a été produit donc vous pouvez avoir des
écarts entre différents ruchers qui sont
même très proches parce que à un
kilomètre près on peut avoir des fleurs
qui sont qui sont assez différentes
et puis après vous pouvez avoir des
miels qui sont assez proches d'une
distance plus éloignée c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment lié à l'environnement
autour qui se trouve autour du rucher
les abeilles peuvent aller environ à 3
km autour mais elles vont vraiment
récolter dans le kilomètre autour du
autour du rocher
vous proposer quoi comme différents
types de miel alors en fait je propose
ce qui arrive et pas c'est pas moi qui
décide en fait je fais deux récoltes par
an une au printemps une en été je peux
avoir c'est généralement du multi floral
en fait je vais pas chercher à faire du
monofloral ce qui est voilà quand on
fait de l'intensif on peut chercher à
faire du multifloral on va un endroit où
il y a tel type de fleur et on va
récolter cette fleur là moi je fais que
deux récoltes par an une au printemps et
une en été si si ça peut c'est pas
toujours le cas et après suivant
l'endroit je vais avoir je sais pas en
été je vais avoir de l'acacia qui va
être mélangé avec du tilleul je vais
avoir du châtaignier enfin voilà ça va
se mélanger des fois j'ai dû
spécifiquement une fleur mais c'est
parce que les autres n'ont pas donné
c'est plutôt ça et vous avez une
technique de récolte particulière ou
pour que ça se fasse suffisamment
à peu près pareil on travaille dans la
même façon quand on intensif la
différence moi c'est que je vais pas
chauffer du tout le miel que ce soit à
l'extraction
ou que ce soit la mise en pot parce que
souvent en fait la problématique c'est
qu'on met le miel mais le miel en fût et
pour après derrière le mettre en pause
il va falloir le chauffer puisqu'il aura
cristallisé donc moi je le mets en pot
directement à la récolte ce qui fait que
de garder ses bienfaits il garde ses
bienfaits voilà tout à fait il est pas
chauffé à chaque fois vous chauffez un
peu le miel
alors en règle générale voilà si on
dépasse 40 dès qu'on dépasse 40 degrés
on va perdre à la fois en bienfait et à
la fois en qualité au niveau du goût on
va perdre aussi une partie des
la qualité du miel voilà il y a beaucoup
d'apiculteurs qui rencontrent des
difficultés face aux dérèglements
climatique c'est aussi votre cas oui
genre je rencontre bien sûr vous voyez
là on est au mois de février et elle
devrait être vraiment elle devrait être
en hivernage elle devrait plus bouger
elle devrait en grappe et ne plus bouger
et elles sont dehors là donc elles sont
en train de récolter du pollen donc si
la saison reste douce comme ça
c'est vrai que ça valait et puis si on
se reprend comme il y a deux ans 15
jours où il a fait -8 et bien derrière
c'est c'est une hécatombe parce que
elles sont là elles sont vraiment
reparties et s'il fait vraiment froid
comme ça là on peut avoir des pères très
très lourdes à votre niveau vous n'êtes
pas inquiet justement par rapport à si
mais après voilà enfin soit on fait pas
enfin c'est vraiment un métier où il
faut accepter les aléas sinon sinon on
travaille pas on essaie moi j'essaie de
faire le maximum pour que voilà elles
est suffisamment de nourriture pour
passer l'hiver qu'elle soit que tout va
bien de sélectionner au mieux de garder
les meilleurs souches pour que ça puisse
s'appuie sanctionner maintenant voilà on
a une part d'Alea ça peut aller pendant
l'hiver on peut perdre quand tout va
bien on perd 5 10% et quand ça va mal
voilà j'ai déjà perdu 80% sur une sur
une année donc là il faut l'accepter ça
sinon vous
vous faites plus d'apiculture et c'est
quoi pour vous une bonne année pour une
année moi qui perd où je perds aller
15-20%, ça va c'est raisonnable et bien
merci beaucoup
notre invitation je vous souhaite un bon
salon de l'agriculture ce dernier se
tiendra du samedi 25 février au 5 mars à
Porte de Versailles demain nous
recevrons la fermeture de grignons qui
sera également présente au salon de
l'agriculture direction trappes
maintenant où se tiendra le Mondial
d'improvisation junior de jeudi à
dimanche prochain événement va réunir
les équipes junior de France de Belgique
du Québec et de la Suisse pendant un 4
jours au conservatoire de musique et de
danse et à la Meuse si jeune yvelinois
vous représenter la France Grégory
canalet les a suivi lors d'un atelier de
préparation regardez
j'en vois un peu plus là
il n'en faut plus jouer à la manière de
Molière l'une des 15 catégories sur
lesquelles planches ces jeunes de Déclic
Théâtre pour le Mondial d'improvisation
junior pour se faire un atelier
hebdomadaire de deux heures pour laisser
place à l'imaginaire car l'impro ça ne
se prépare pas actuellement on travaille
la catégorie Shakespeare aujourd'hui la
selle de Molière et en plus on va
continuer de travailler de répéter en
fait c'est pas une répétition parce que
l'improvisation peut pas refaire ce
qu'on a ce qu'on vient de faire parce
que c'est l'imagination ça laisse place
à notre imagination vraiment l'impro
alors que le théâtre classique enfin tu
es moins libre alors qu'à l'impro tu es
vraiment qui tu veux et tout ça je
trouve ça je trouve que c'est bien du 23
au 26 février à Trappes c'est si jeunes
de 15 à 18 ans représenteront la France
face au Québec à la Belgique et à la
Suisse bonjour monsieur
voyez-vous j'ai un chapeau de détective
j'ai le pose ici et puis une pipe vous
êtes effectué je suis détective loupe
ils ont été sélectionnés au sein de la
troupe des juniors de Déclic Théâtre par
leur coach dont la comédienne Amel
Amziane
donc si lui il s'avance de ce côté-là
toi tu en profite pour aller t'avancer
de ce côté-là et là de son côté sur la
capitaine de l'équipe de France s'il y a
des problèmes avec l'arbitre Nono je
serai là s'il y a des problèmes entre
nous enfin en interne on va dire je
serai là je serai un peu la maman du
groupe je m'occupais des de mes
coéquipiers et tout ça va être cool
c'est un joli melting pot tant sur les
parcours des unes et des uns tant sur
les origines
yvelinoise et temps sur les années
d'improvisation donc finalement on a des
gens qui qui reviennent à l'impro dans
cette équipe on a des on a des personnes
qui en font depuis maintenant 8 ans donc
il y a un joyeux mélange dans cette
équipe et on va voir ce que ça donnera
sur la patinoire à partir du 23 février
l'année dernière Suisse les juniors de
Déclic Théâtre avaient décroché la
deuxième place derrière la Belgique le
titre est jouable pour cette édition à
domicile mais le Mondial d'impro c'est
avant tout un moment de partage Cédric
rencontré des Suisses des Belges et
québécois c'est vrai que ça va être ça
va être quelque chose surtout que on va
découvrir c'est pas du tout le même
personnalité les gens qu'on rencontre
dans la patinoire ça ça devient des
vrais amis même s'ils habitent au Canada
en Belgique ou en Suisse donc d'abord le
fait de prendre du plaisir et ensuite si
on arrive deuxième ou premier on va pas
on va pas cracher dessus d'entrer la
France affrontera la Belgique au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse le
23 février le Mondial d'improvisation
s'achèvera le 26 février une finale au
programme à la Meurice de Trappes vous
êtes tous les mêmes
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est l'heure maintenant de passer
à notre partie sport
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous mais qu'elle est
midron on commence par du sport
mécanique retenez bien son nom Arthur
laurier il vient de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il va participer
en 2023 au championnat de France junior
de karting y participera également au
championnat d'Europe junior de karting
électrique nous avons la chance de
recevoir Arthur avec son père Lionel sur
ce plateau on l'a vu précédemment alors
Arthur est-ce que c'est une grosse année
2023 en perspective
[Musique]
je l'année dernière était un année
d'entraînement donc cette année je vais
tout faire pour viser le podium à chaque
course je vais découvrir l'électrique
aussi car
la première je pense que l'électrique ça
va
ça s'installe de plus en plus dans le
sport mécanique donc m'entraîner déjà à
changer de motorisation de pneus
de catégorie et tout ça ça
m'entraînement dans le domaine du
karting oui pourquoi parce que déjà le
couple maximum à l'accélération alors
qu'en thermique il y a une courbe de
puissance
irrégulière et puis c'est pas les mêmes
cartes non plus sans niveau poids
faut s'adapter très vite on sent
l'expert déjà
alors Lionel en 2023 grosse année
comment on faites vous pour
l'accompagner en tant que parents en
tant que parents on s'adapte franchement
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un agenda compliqué entre les
entraînements les courses il faut
jongler entre tout ça et puis bah du
coup les déplacements sont quand même
assez lointains puisque on va aller
aussi bien jusqu'au tout au nord de
l'Angleterre donc c'est quand même des
gros gros déplacements
nous nous présenter un petit peu votre
parcours Arthur là vous êtes passionné
de voiture depuis l'âge de 5 ans mais
c'est quand même assez récent finalement
cette entrée dans les dans les sports
mécaniques
donc j'ai débuté le karting à 10 ans
juste après le confinement donc à la SM
nantaise le karting par contre je
n'avais pas là pour faire l'école de
karting qui permet tous les mercredis
après-midi de se retrouver avec les
animateurs et de d'apprendre par exemple
à freiner à faire des zigzags etc donc
j'ai débuté le quart tout seul avec mon
propre carte son coach et au bout de six
mois j'étais déjà recordman de la piste
dans ma catégorie donc après j'ai fait
que l'améliorer jusqu'à passer en
National
cette année
début 2022 je rappelle que vous avez 12
ans et demi actuellement
Lionel vous n'êtes pas une famille de
pilote finalement pas du tout ni de
pilote ni autour de la compétition
automobile du coup on apprend en fait on
apprend et c'est vrai que c'est pas un
apprentissage facile parce que
finalement déjà 12 ans il faut c'est à
dire entre guillemets c'est déjà un peu
vieux parce que la plupart des
concurrents en fait qu'il affrontent ont
déjà entre 5 et 8 voire plus d'années
d'expérience alors que lui bah
finalement ce n'est que sa deuxième
année donc c'est c'est vrai que il faut
enfin il va fallu tout mettre en place
en fait moi j'ai aussi appris la
mécanique pour faire la mécanique avec
lui quand il a besoin de d'un mécanicien
en entraînement parce que c'est vrai
qu'on faut pas l'oublier c'est pour
mécanique c'est à la fois un pilote mais
c'est aussi
que tu d'équipes mécanicien et autres et
un sac dans les pilotes très
expérimentés qui font ça depuis très
longtemps ils ont des équipes avec leur
mécano etc tandis que nous on est
relativement débutants donc on est on
est encore en fait tout seul on essaie
d'avoir de plus en plus l'aide d'un
coach aussi pour pouvoir l'aider à
progresser mais c'est vrai que c'est
toute une organisation à voir c'est dur
de rentrer dans ce monde
déjà c'est un tout petit monde enfin
tout le monde se connaît
oui c'est dur parce que déjà il faut que
je rattrape l'expérience que les autres
seront déjà acquises donc c'est c'était
l'année dernière j'ai tout fait pour
rattraper l'expérience sur les départs
en cours comme en doubler
et alors à quel moment vous vous êtes
dit je vais faire du karting pour pour
le loisir et puis ensuite c'est passé a
vraiment je veux me spécialiser dans le
karting bah je veux presque en faire mon
métier plus tard à l'âge de 5 ans
j'avais déjà l'objectif de faire du
karting donc j'ai dû attendre jusqu'à 7
ans et demi pour pouvoir en faire
réellement en loisir mais faute de temps
j'ai pu commencer que à 10 ans et demi
donc le quartier loisir n'a rien à voir
en fait avec le quartier de compétition
c'est c'est pas du tout les mêmes
vitesses quand c'est assez c'est assez
incroyable et
c'est vrai que en fait on en faisait un
peu en loisir précédemment mais
tout à l'heure en fait il y a des écoles
de karting qui sont finalement pour
entre les enfants entre 7 et 10 ans le
problème c'est qu'il faut les connaître
quand on n'est pas quand on n'est pas du
milieu en fait on les connaît pas leur
visibilité commence à s'améliorer mais
objectivement nous on l'a pris trop tard
en fait
donc c'est vrai que c'est comme il l'a
dit comme disait Arthur c'est un petit
milieu mais quand on vient pas de ce
milieu là
il faut apprendre faut vraiment
apprendre au fur et à mesure et
bah on apprend aussi de ces erreurs donc
des fois voilà on a on a parfois perdu
un peu de temps mais Arthur avait le
talent pour pour justement rattraper ce
retard en fait qu'on avait qu'on avait
pris
et à 5 ans déjà tu savais que tu voulais
devenir pilote professionnel j'avais
déjà joué déjà les Grands Prix de F1
justement est-ce qu'il y a une
préférence enfin quelqu'un qui qui vous
a inspiré Arthur pilote j'ai trois
idoles j'ai
mon pourcent de travail ça a déterm
iner le travail avec enfin il était tout
le temps sur
la c'est un peu lui qui formait la
voiture en fait c'est lui qui dit que tu
es au mécano comment
[Musique]
comment régler la voiture après j'ai
Jacques Villeneuve pour la triple
couronne et qu'il a failli avoir avec
sa deuxième place en endurant au 24
heures du Mans en 2008 et j'ai Lewis
Hamilton aussi pour
Karina en fait il a jamais baissé les
bras même s'il a tout réussi donc il a 7
titres de champion du monde il a
de victoires comme ça et il en veut
toujours plus
et au niveau de votre plus belle
expérience Arthur alors vous avez
participé à votre premier championnat de
France d'endurance au saumon c'était en
2021 c'est vraiment l'un des meilleurs
moments de votre carrière pour l'instant
vous terminez sur le podium je crois
c'est cela sur la troisième marche avant
seconde du deuxième c'était les 90
minutes du Mans
encadé c'était
dur déjà parce que tenir 15 minutes dans
le kart
en étant focalisé
[Musique]
j'avais encore du mal à
rester focus mais maintenant j'arrive à
rester focus pendant 20 30 minutes et
c'était l'une de ces premières courses
Lionel
justement ce que vous avez été surpris
de ces six bons résultats
dès les débuts totalement surpris parce
que c'est vrai que c'est jamais évident
en fait quand on est dans des conditions
de course on a tout peut se passer et ça
risque qui m'a surpris c'est que
finalement
il a fait que améliorer ses temps tout
le long de la course donc c'est c'était
aussi un signe que en fait plus plus
l'expérience venait aussi parce que
quand c'est la première course il y a
pas mal de choses auxquelles on a un peu
d'appréhension parce que on les connaît
pas forcément et on a bien vu que à un
moment donné c'était c'était passé
c'était devenu presque naturel et du
coup les tons continuent à tomber et ça
c'était vraiment super sympa et en 2022
vous intégrer la catégorie junior auke j
alors ils sont présents les meilleurs
pilotes âgés de 12 à 15 ans
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette catégorie
Arthur donc c'est une catégorie où les
moteurs déjà sont
c'est la seule catégorie en France avoir
ces moteurs là donc c'est organisé par
la FFSA Academy
qui est une école de karting et de F4 et
[Musique]
en fait c'est 5 course dans l'année on a
un coach qui change toutes les courses
et donc tous les meetings les coachs
font
ils analysent les cours pour nous donner
les courbes des autres pour pouvoir
savoir où est-ce qu'il faut freiner plus
tard ou est-ce qu'il faut réaccélérer
plus tôt ici quelle trajectoire est-ce
qu'on prend ici quelques trajectoire il
faut prendre
etc il y a plein de paramètres sur
lesquels les couches jouent donc ils
jouent dans ce championnat on touche pas
aux cartes donc il y a pas de réglage
moteur il y a pas de réglage châssis à
part l'élargissement des voies
donc c'est aussi pour les aider à
progresser et puis ce qui est aussi
sympa c'est que on cherche pas à
compenser une éventuelle
enfin éventuelle
coup de moins bien du pilote par la
machine puisque dans d'autres catégories
c'est un peu des fois la machine qui
fait que le bal pilote gagne aussi bah
là les résultats c'est vraiment le
pilote qui fait la différence puisque
c'est le matériel pour tout ça et tu
roules jusqu'à combien de kilomètres
heure
j'ai fait 126 à Varennes et ça va la
vitesse te fait pas peur non
j'en demande plus
très bien et bien merci beaucoup Arthur
et Lionel laurier d'être venu en plateau
avec nous du coup on suivra ta carrière
de très près on poursuit maintenant aux
informations enfin résultat sportifs du
week-end nickel et on commence par du
football
ont joué ce weekend la demi-finale de la
Coupe mutuelle Île-de-France plus connue
sous le nom de Coupe de Paris le FC
Mantois qui évoluerait affronter
Hardricourt club ambitieux qui est voulu
actuellement en R3 2 division en dessous
et se sont finalement les joueurs de
menthe qui l'ont emporté sur le plus
petit à des scores le résumé du match
des images de Céline Charles deux
équipes ivinoise pour une place en
finale de la Coupe de Paris le FC
Mantois qui évolue en R1 recevait ce
dimanche hardricour une équipe de R3 dès
le coup d'envoi les deux divisions ne se
font pas ressentir malgré quelques
situations pour les joueurs locaux le
score à la pause est 0 à 0 en football
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait pris des
leçons au contraire on a fait le jeu
habituel c'est on joue au foot on a bien
démarré le match maintenant on n'a pas
su concrétiser les peu d'opportunités
qu'on a eu et après bah ils ont joué
kramment de leur chance en travaillant
avec un blog bas au retour des
vestiaires même scénario le FC Mantois
domine mais n'arrive pas à être vraiment
dangereux devant le but la délivrance
s'arrivera finalement toute fin de match
sur ce coup franc un à zéro
un très court pousse mais n'arrivera pas
à revenir le FC Mantois étant final bah
ça se joue sur un coup de pied arrêté
donc voilà c'est ça aurait pu être de
l'autre côté aussi donc c'est un détail
je trouve que c'est un détail et que en
tout cas je l'ai félicite parce qu'ils
ont ils ont joué avec leurs atouts et
ils nous ont mis en difficulté tout
simplement et bah déception parce que
franchement on a fait pratiquement jeu
égal avec une équipe que une très très
bonne équipe de R1 qui qui va remonter
en m3 parce que c'est au moins sa place
si ce n'est plus donc on est content en
plus à se jouer sur sur peu de choses
sur un détail le FC Mantois connaîtra
son adversaire le 5 mars prochain il
s'agira de Vincennes de
Neuilly-sur-Marne ou de Paris 15
et bravo FC Montois pour sa
qualification ce week-end Michael ont
joué également en coupe des Yvelines on
connaît les qualifier pour les
demi-finales de l'épreuve
du FC Montois Aubergenville se qualifie
au tir au but face à l'équipe 3 de
Versailles Remouillé s'impose contre
Sartrouville 2 et enfin Les Mureaux se
font sortir par où deux au tir au but le
prochain tour et programmé le 9 avril
prochain dans le championnat de National
de Versailles c'est encore imposé se
vend l'histoire sur la pelouse de
Dunkerque le score de Busin avec un but
et une passe décisive de l'attaquant
néerlandais jereman Lens au classement
Versailles reprend la première place
avec 39 points engranger depuis le début
de la saison Martigues le deuxième a un
match de retard il y avait également un
tournoi de futsal ce week-end la ville
de plaisir en partenariat avec le club
du FO plaisir organisé une compétition
ce samedi 18 février au Palais des
Sports Pierre de Coubertin au programme
de le deuxième édition un tournoi
féminin pour aller à 14-17 ans et un
tournoi masculin pour les plus de 18 ans
on écoute un organisateur et un
participant au micro de TV 78 l'objectif
c'est l'accès au sport libre notamment
avec le foot salle là cet après-midi
nous avons 10 équipes engagées
aucun ne sont dans des clubs ou certains
sont peut-être au top mais la plupart
sont viennent
sont hors club en fait et ils viennent
jouer viennent partager un moment de
sport je suis inscrit parce que moi ça
faisait longtemps que j'ai pas fait de
foot je suis un mec de plaisir ouais FOP
j'ai fait 10 ans de foot à plaisir et
donc du coup j'ai vu qu'il y avait le
tournoi qui qui était sur le site de la
ville et donc je me suis dit pourquoi
pas monter une une équipe quoi avec avec
des anciens aussi parce que tous mes
amis c'était quasiment des anciens du
FOP en fait
et on va maintenant parler de rugby
Michael avec le championnat de fédéral 2
oui tout à fait Mathilde dans le
championnat de fédéral 2 plaisir c'est
fait plaisir face à Boulogne-Billancourt
ce week-end ils se sont imposés 85 à 7
dans le même temps Versailles c'est
imposé 29 à 21 façade au classement les
plaisirs sont deuxième et Versailles est
toujours à 6e il y avait également du
handball ce week-end dans le championnat
de National 3 nouvelle défaite pour
plaisir des clés l'équipe s'est inclinée
sur le score de 24 à 20 sur le terrain
de cher bourgeoise manche l'autre équipe
ibinoise où il le Vésinet carrière s'est
imposé 31 à 24 face à avenir du pont non
il prend la cinquième place plaisir et
huitième on va parler un peu de basket
nickel avec un match qui a déchaîné
toutes les passions en basket c'était le
match à ne pas manquer les lycées
versaillés Sainte-Geneviève Ginette et
hoche se sont affrontés dans un match
qui s'est a dérouler ce jeudi 16 février
au gymnase mauboron de Versailles un
match sulfureux qui côté par la victoire
de Ginette retour sur la rencontre des
images de Grégory canalet un montage de
Thomas Fletcher dans ce reportage je
vous emmène dans l'une des ambulences
les plus chaudes de France le match
entre les lycées Versailles Ginette
Sainte-Geneviève et hoche c'est parti
[Musique]
du train incroyable incroyable
ça fait une semaine qu'on chante tous
les soirs dans le rêve bien sûr 600
personnes ce soir voire plus Ginette
c'est incroyable je vous dis
[Musique]
je sais pas s'il y a plus de bruit mais
c'est toujours aussi émouvant
c'est complètement fou on le savait on
espérait et chaque année on est surpris
et on est heureux après plusieurs
minutes la souris pour les tribunes
s'embrasent au moment de l'entrée des
joueurs Hoche tenant du titre veut
décrocher sa troisième victoire mais
pour l'instant c'est Ginette qui mène 14
à 2 Ginette Hoche s'est avant tout un
show les organisateurs ont voulu créer
un événement unique en France au
programme concours de dunk football
freestyle DJ et un concert de deux
chanteuses une de H en rouge et une de
Ginette en bleu
[Musique]
également proposé des chorégraphies
acrobatiques un spectacle répété depuis
la rentrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est des jeunes joueurs et c'est pas
leur métier mais mais c'est ça a été
très intéressant donc
[Applaudissements]
et le match se termine par une victoire
de Ginette sur le score de 47 à 38 face
à Auch au bilan des confrontations ça
fait 15 à 2 pour Ginette et ils font la
fête on était très prolifique on a été
plus prolifique
la défaite on l'accepte la défaite on
l'accepte mais honnêtement c'était
formidable mais l'année prochaine on a
gagné l'année dernière on leur laisse la
victoire voilà c'est comme ça c'est la
vie mais bon c'est pas grave on garde le
sourire on va boire là maintenant
c'était génial
il y avait une super ambiance et merci
aux joueurs et merci à maman aussi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça fait de remporter ce
choc là je suis hyper heureuse j'avoue
que tout le match est un peu douté parce
que c'était serré je pense qu'on a eu un
temps fort au 4e carton avec mentalement
il y a un truc qui a changé on a eu un
ou deux tiers et la mentalement on s'est
dit on va le faire on va le faire et là
là c'est parti donc je pense que c'est
ça ouais donc je suis hyper heureux
on a gagné mais c'était surtout une
fabuleuse soirée pleine de de belles
choses de toi une parenthèse étoilée
dans un monde où les élèves font des au
travail beaucoup je perds les mots
excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
rendez-vous l'année prochaine pour une
18e édition le public en redemande
[Musique]
des ambiances et les organisateurs
espèrent voir Tony Parker peut-être
l'année prochaine en tout cas il a
failli perdre cette année il devrait
venir normalement l'année prochaine en
tout cas c'est le souhait des
organisateurs alors on termine ce
Ginette Hoche 2023 par une interview qui
nous a fait beaucoup rire à la fin du
match on était à la fin du match Ginette
venez de gagner un supporter de hausse
est parti dans un monologue on l'a vu
dans le reportage précédent mais là on a
la version longue on adore et on savoure
forcément déçu forcément déçu forcément
le sentiment quelque chose tous ces
penalty mon on était très prolifique on
a été plus politiques que Ginette tu as
perdu mais c'est en terme de réalisme le
réalisme il a pas été là nous on a été
prolifique bordel on a été pour les
filles et l'ambiance et l'ambiance
allait être là là loin de personnes plus
on vient qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai plus de voix
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe regardez La Dépêche on l'accepte
la défaite on l'accepte mais honnêtement
c'était formidable c'était très bien si
tu dis n'importe quoi écoutez pas on
adore en tout cas il a plus de voix
juste avant on pouvait plus avoir de
voix à la fin à la fin alors rendez-vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition a forcément ce sera en 2024 il y
aura encore plus de choses à nous
promettre les organisateurs François
lamant l'organisateur travaille déjà sur
la prochaine édition et pourquoi pas
Tony Parker et vous y serez Michael
évidemment pour vous faire vivre une
nouvelle fois ce match Ginette Hoche
merci c'est précisions Michael on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle page sport c'est bientôt la fin
de cette émission mais juste avant je
vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel sera de nouveau un peu
brumeux sur l'ensemble du département
selon Météo France au niveau des
températures et de faire environ 3 à 2
degrés dans l'après-midi nous devrions
avoir quelques éclaircies à percevoir le
soleil comptez 10 degrés du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et 11
degrés vers ou dans et Rambouillet et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]